[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome to the
pandemic starts with me webinar
presented by the minority nevada
minority health and equity coalition
unlv school of public health and caesars
entertainment my name is gwen mageeta
i'm the vice president of diversity
equity and inclusion and social impact
for caesars entertainment i'll be your
moderator for today
today's presenters are an esteemed panel
of uh professionals uh physician i would
say doctors except for me uh dr brian
labis dr erica marquez dr francisco c
and dr christina madison each one of
them are esteemed panelists and
represent a complementary expertise
so our panel today will speak on the
current stages of the pandemic myths and
concerns to overcome
well noted that we've had over a year of
the pandemic and many conversations have
occurred but there is still more to
learn and more to consider and discuss
as we are shifting to a new phase or a
different phase of the pandemic
really working to achieve higher
vaccination rates among minorities
this is the first such discussion
externally that several of the sponsors
have collaborated on in the gaming
industry as well
so as your moderator i'll be sharing a
bit more background on each as i go into
specific questions we'll have some time
for q a in the end we hope so please
submit them in the q a function or the
chat and we'll be monitoring that as
well
so the first question goes to dr labis
who comes to us with a very interesting
background on outbreak investigations
disease surveillance and implementing
public health uh informa informatic
systems
so dr levis as we just diving deeper
deeper into this pandemic in the current
phase what's what's currently going on
in nevada and locally in southern nevada
could you share a bit of the updates and
directives from the governor as well
sure um well if you look at the nevada
data it's really skewed by southern
nevada so everything we look at we talk
about statewide unfortunately it shows
us really what's happening here but um
for the past two or three months we've
seen this continual increase in cases of
cobit uh starting around the beginning
of july we've seen this this big
increase i guess early june we've seen
this increase going on week over week
we're finally at a point where it looks
like it's plateaued maybe starting to to
decrease but we have a lot of disease
transmission going on we're still at
high levels for it and most of that
transmission is happening uh because of
the delta variant that has been the
thing that's changed all the numbers
nationwide and unfortunately in nevada
we were kind of leading the charge with
uh the delta variants so things hit us
here especially in southern nevada
sooner uh than they did in the rest of
the country and uh we've seen that that
gradual increase hopefully we're turning
the corner now where things are starting
to decline which would be similar to the
pattern we saw last year just delayed by
three or four weeks or so uh in northern
nevada they're seeing the same sort of
thing it just wasn't didn't hit them as
early and didn't hit them as hard early
on as it did for us uh they're seeing
more of that transmission now they're a
bit behind us but if you look statewide
those numbers just get washed out by the
total number of people from southern
nevada um but the delta variant has
really hit us hard and that's driven
everything that we've seen the majority
of the cases are still in unvaccinated
people and if we look at
hospitalizations and deaths uh though
that's what's basically uh happening in
unvaccinated people we're not seeing uh
that many hospitalizations or deaths in
our vaccinated population uh it's really
the unvaccinated people that still
continue to drive this pandemic
and also with school starting um what
what is the vaccination
timeline for children under 12.
well for children under 12 that's the
one group we're still uh waiting to get
the fda approval when they went to the
fda for their approval the fda said they
wanted six months of follow-up data not
the two months the two months of data is
what they used for the emergency use
authorization so by requesting more data
it just takes longer to collect that
data which means it's going to take some
time before they can get the approval
for children under 12. those clinical
trials are going on right now they're
still collecting data on
on all those kids we're just not at the
point where we have the results of those
trials and can move to the approval
process so it's still going to be a
little while before we can uh see a
vaccine for kids uh likely sometime in
the new year i don't think they'll
they'll get through that six months have
it analyzed uh submitted and approved
before the end of the year but uh by
early next year is when we should be
talking about that in children
okay
my kids my daughter is going to
kindergarten so i'll be prepared for
that as well in about a week um
so the next series of questions go to dr
madison and dr c with dr madison's
background on
really looking at infectious
communicable diseases as well and dr c
just with the background on cdc and
national institutes of health just
from your perspectives how is cobin 19
affected affecting ethnic minority
groups for example why are the most
vulnerable how can we address vaccine
hesitantly hesitancy among these groups
as well
yeah so i'll go ahead and and start uh
off the conversation i think the biggest
thing
that i've seen is access to care and
then ultimately
um we're seeing issues around the
digital divide so um initially when we
first started scheduling appointments
everything was done online and so i
think that unfortunately as well as some
of the skepticism within uh you know our
bipod community and in particular our
black community um about whether or not
this vaccine was something that they
thought was going to be good for them um
you know i think that that really caused
some uh consternations
right at the beginning when we first
started uh rolling out the vaccine last
december and early january when we were
targeting the elderly and them you know
compromised and people who were at high
risk
and so
even when we had people who were
eligible they may not have known where
to go to get access to the appointment
right so i really do think that it comes
down to access and then um being able to
educate and getting those campaigns out
to those communities of color and so for
me personally i was very open and honest
about my vaccine journey because again i
wanted to be an example as a woman of
color and then you know being boots on
the ground going in and and doing
vaccine clinics at places like historic
west side and you know places like
nevada partners whereas you know
majority african-american population but
even when we were doing that we were
still seeing um not as many people from
from the actual community and the zip
codes that we were at actually coming to
the clinics and so now
um again i think those people who are
sort of in that movable middle um still
need their questions answered and we
really just have to take this one-on-one
approach to making sure that people
understand why it's so important because
they're at such high risk because we've
just seen the health disparities and
equities just being exacerbated so much
by this pandemic
thank you for that
yeah for a lot of minority population
there's lack of trust
there's a lot of
miscommunication
mixed signals being sent by the
government and different groups so that
some people really are misinformed or
they
look at social media and and if you look
at certain social media they always give
you a lot of
wrong information and they believe
whatever is in print or in what they see
in the internet so i think
um
i think basically
we need to really
be
more transparent about things and so
that people will understand and get the
message that
is very important that they protect
themselves and their family and they can
protect other people too so that at this
point in time we want to make sure
we play a role there's an effective
vaccine available so
use it and protect yourself and your
family
and dr mike has you've done a lot of
work on health equity and access i'm
curious to know from your perspective
what what is the balance between access
and education or influence i guess so
there's a big
multitude of um
what would it take to get
other minorities over the hump to get
the uh the vaccine yeah so now we've
been doing a ton of work since the
beginning of the panda pandemic really
providing education on uncovered risk
and now on the vaccine and you know i
think one of our really hardest
challenges right now at this point in
the pandemic is the amount of
disinformation
and misinformation because it's almost
hard for us to keep up with that and so
i think that you know that's one of our
biggest challenges in thinking about
equity because um our communities are so
confused and with you know you can go on
to like dr c mentioned you can go onto
any social media platform and there's
folks sharing so much information and
sometimes they're medical providers too
right and that has added a whole layer
of challenges for us in response to this
pandemic so you know thinking about like
how do we who do we trust and so there's
there's
there's so much legitimacy in terms of
like why people are still at a point
where they're hesitant about taking the
vaccine and so one of the things that we
have been trying to educate our
community on is really about
um knowing where that source of
information is coming from are there
like intentions by this someone trying
to sell you some vitamins that they
think this is going to be our cure to
the vaccine i mean to covet um are are
there other things are they directing
you to non-scientific websites or
information or even sometimes it looks
like they're interpreting data that is
inaccurate um and so this has been
really like at this point in the game
it's really been our challenge in really
trying to keep up with the amount of
misinformation that is being shared
amongst our community members and we
have really been focused on the
groundwork with community partners our
trusted leaders in the community to
really get a grip of like what's
happening what are those conversations
and helping them um get that information
that accurate information out into the
community
all right thank you so back to dr labis
and dr madison um just speaking about
what dr marquez is alluding to what what
are some of the top let's just say top
five myths you're hearing and how do you
would you address them one-on-one like
what are the answers to the myths in
general so we can
look out for them
do you want to start on this one dr
lavis or i'll let you start go ahead
okay
so top five
uh the vaccine's gonna change your dna
so that's number one
right so let me dispel that one first
and foremost so uh the messenger rna
vaccines that we have so both pfizer and
moderna and i like to tell people that
the mrna vaccines are like the snapchat
of vaccination so it shows your immune
cells a picture and then it kind of
disappears it doesn't enter the nucleus
which is where your dna is it can't
change your dna um it's it's rna so it
can't do anything to your dna um so
that's number one um the second myth um
is that there is a microchip in the
vaccine
that is also a myth and is not accurate
um considering the amount of fluid um
that uh we are currently injecting in
you and the uh needle that we are using
it is impossible for us to get a
microchip in there so that is also um
incorrect
number three is that um it can impact
your future fertility there has been no
evidence
and on to the contrary it's actually
being recommended in pregnant and
breastfeeding women
number four
is that if you are
if you have severe allergies you can't
get this vaccine
which is also not true
so at the very beginning of the pandemic
we did see people having allergic
reactions to the vaccine um but
obviously within an abundance of caution
we told people who had history of severe
allergies to like food or medication to
just make sure that they had their
epipens with them and just to understand
that that's a possibility but that
didn't really bore out any um you know
anything that was uh demonstrably
different from just the general
population and allergies and allergic
reactions and i think the fifth and the
last one um that i would say is that
um that the vaccine
um somehow is going to make you magnetic
which is also not true
and so
it does not change your body chemistry
it does not change your dna it does not
suddenly make you magnetic um i i wish
it would
make me uh you know have a magnetic more
magnetic personality maybe more people
would get it
but that is those are the top five that
i could tell you um and hopefully i
dispelled some of those myths but those
are the big ones that i've heard
and i would add there's a broad category
of misunderstanding that's it's separate
from individual myths but it's the idea
that the vaccine is unsafe and untested
and that could not be more wrong all the
parts that are in the vaccine have been
used for years and tested
the idea that this vaccine was put
together too quickly well it was only
because we spent decades getting to the
point where we could put it together
quickly it's kind of like saying you
know i called the fire department and
they got here too quickly well yeah they
didn't have to build the trucks and hire
people it was all ready to go when there
was an emergency and that's what we did
with this vaccine it is shown to be safe
and effective we've tested it thoroughly
and people looked at that the fda
emergency use approval and said well it
wasn't tested yes it was it was just a
different way of approving things
because there was a public health
emergency so i think all those questions
about safety are valid concerns to have
uh unfortunately uh it scared people off
from getting the vaccine and none of
those things are true it is a very safe
and effective vaccine
incredible with the age of information
there's also the the dis
in front of the information as well
because it's
uh very confusing speaking about
confusion some of the feedback has also
been over the booster shot to the need
for a third dose to have this work what
is your reaction to that for for any of
you on the panel
regarding the booster shots
right
yeah because uh
based on studies they've done they've
seen that
after the second dose i think
your immunity would uh weigh
they'll be awaiting immunity toward
a few months later so if you do the
booster eight months after your second
dose you know you increase your
immunity to it
so that's why they're recommending a
booster shot
later on when and when it's rolled out
uh i think later part of september and
then they start again with the elderly
and
and the frontliners before they reach to
the general population right now it's
only for the immuno compromise where
transplant patients the
those who accurately it with hiv or
those
being treated with chemotherapy so those
are people that need it right now
because they're even suppressed
go ahead christina
no i was just gonna add um sort of this
concept because i think uh you know
explaining the difference between the
booster versus the third dose so
when dr c mentioned the
immunocompromised population we want
people to understand that we want you to
go and get that third dose now because
you most likely did not get an adequate
response from the first two doses so
really we were
we're encouraging you to do that now
because we want you to have better
protection because you probably didn't
get the same level of protection as
someone else who wasn't amino suppressed
so that was the big thing i wanted to
stress and then the booster dose which
is hopefully going to be rolled out
around the week of september 20th that
not to rush out and try to go get that
now
that you really should wait
based on when you got that second dose
and then ultimately johnson johnson
actually just released a statement today
it was just a press release it wasn't
data but that the booster dose for the
johnson and johnson dose is actually
probably coming soon as well so remember
the messenger rna vaccines were
initiated in december of 2020 versus the
johnson johnson we didn't start using
that until march and so that eight
months is probably going to be a little
bit further off and so i think a lot of
people were anxious if they got johnson
johnson because they didn't know what to
do they're like hey what about us but it
looks like the data is supporting giving
a second dose and that that second dose
actually boosts those
virus neutralizing antibodies probably
about nine times more than what they got
from the first one so it's really good
news i think for people that you know
it's coming and we really just want to
increase that durability of the vaccine
not just the safety and the efficacy
side but that it lasts as long as
possible so that we can really weather
the storm with this delta variant
yeah i think this is this is exactly
what we expect to see with a new vaccine
we try it in a population and we see
what happens over time we can't tell you
what's going to happen with your
antibody levels five years from now
because nobody's been vaccinated for
five years and if you look back at all
the vaccines we give to kids we started
by having a one or two dose series and a
lot of times added booster doses to that
uh we had measles was a single shot
vaccine and then we saw a breakthrough
case with that added uh another dose of
the measles vaccine we did the same
thing with chickenpox and so we start
out with our basic understanding of
these and often we learn that we need to
boost the immune system and so this is
exactly what's expected it doesn't mean
it failed it doesn't mean it didn't work
this is how we learn about things and
this is how we move forward with using
those vaccines as best we can
and what is some of the hesitancy is
also about um waiting for
the vaccine to be fda approved from what
i'm hearing what what exactly does that
mean for for the vaccine to be fda
approved for any of you
what what difference does that make in
uh in the
the the actual workings of the the
vaccine um relative to say myth or
hesitancy
i guess i'll go first then um so
um there's no difference in the vaccine
the vaccine is the exact same one before
fda approval as it was after fda
approval it comes down to the basic uh
difference in the way we approve
vaccines so when there's an emergency
situation
there is a pressing need for that so we
want to use that vaccine sooner it
doesn't mean we skip steps it doesn't
mean we don't show that it's safe or
anything like that
but we go through an emergency use
process which doesn't require as long of
a follow-up typically so we can get it
to market sooner well we've done that
we've vaccinated close to four billion
people worldwide with our different
vaccines so we've been following these
for some time we have a ton of data now
that shows everything we we saw from
that initial emergency use was correct
it's safe it's effective uh something
that that should be used with our
population so they went back and had the
the full approval from the fda they just
looked at longer term data that showed
the exact same thing uh so in terms of
uh what the vaccine does it doesn't make
a difference in terms of the way it's
administered or what's included that's
all the same the only difference is
sometimes the legal issues around the
vaccine we had some discussions about
could you mandate people to get a
vaccine that has emergency use approval
or not
now that whole issue has just gone away
and so basically it's a uh it's a
longer-term follow-up for the fda uh to
look at those vaccines but it also
doesn't mean that we're done uh once we
approve a vaccine there's an entire
process of following it as long as we
use it to look for side effects look for
problems see if something goes wrong
with it down the road that we you know
if it happens one in a billion times
we're not going to see it if we only
test it now 100 000 people or something
like that so it's really the uh the time
we bring it to market the company can
now give it a brand name some things
like that so you might hear it called
something different it doesn't change
anything though it's still the same
vaccine it was before just as safe just
as effective and recommended just like
it has been for the past year
i also just wanted to make one other
clarification so as of right now there's
only one
uh
vaccine that has received this fda
approval so that's the pfizer vaccine
and specifically it was for what the
initial emergency resp
use authorization was applied for so um
the 16 and up category and the reason
why i make this clarification is because
i don't want parents to think that oh no
it's only fda approved for 16 and up
which means i cannot get my kids
vaccinated which is absolutely not true
we still have an emergency use
authorization in place for the 12 to 15
year old age group and hopefully
sometime before the end of this year
we'll also get it for the younger age
group and the under 12 age group as well
and so i just wanted to make that
clarification because of our vaccinated
we know that the smallest portion of
those who are eligible to be vaccinated
are our adolescents and our young adults
so we really want to make sure people
understand that even though this fda
approval was specific to the 16 and up
that doesn't mean that you shouldn't be
getting your adolescents vaccinated
thank you for that
so how so we have probably more casino
resort hospitality um audience on this
on this uh webinar how can casinos and
resorts work with entities like
yourselves and the uh the school of
public health as well as as a coalition
the minority health and equity coalition
really to focus on improving the health
of the the community how important are
partnerships like this thank you to dr
marquez yeah absolutely um if anything
we learned throughout this pandemic is
that this is work we can't do alone and
our business leaders are such a key
component of this process so this really
is a stepping stone for us to be able to
solidify a collaboration to continue to
help inform um you know your your group
your audience um and it's so important
because you know we have to keep our
finger on the pulse on what's the
concerns in our community um and we have
to be responsive i think throughout this
entire pandemic we have continuously
tried to pivot to make sure that we're
addressing the concerns that we're
hearing on the ground that we're
addressing the misinformation or just
really just sometimes just questions and
concerns you know if i have a
comorbidity um should i be taking the
vaccine like absolutely yes and we've
had we've deployed
um you know pharmacists physicians to be
at vaccination sites that they're
answering the questions because even
even if people show up at our
vaccination sites we know that they
still have questions so we've been
trying to ease those concerns as as
those immunization sites go up in the
communities
but really again
bring that a forum to be able to address
the questions and concerns as they arise
it has been really key for us to be able
to continue to adequately respond to
this pandemic
so are there specific projects or
actions that uh say i'm i'm speaking to
uh we have a corporate responsibility
coalition with nevada resorts or one of
the the sponsors as well what what
should i be asking my counterparts to do
to support uh your efforts
as you know we're very opera also
yeah no um we co-lead the nevada vaccine
equity collaborative with immunized
nevada really a call the action from our
governor
um and having our business leaders part
of that conversation it's again it's
it's really about opening that line of
communication for us to know what are
the needs for you as a business for your
for your employees and how do we address
that and i think that has what has been
key in helping us pivot constantly
throughout this pandemic what
information do we need to deliver who
are the people we need to tap on the
shoulder such as this amazing panel of
speakers who we often pull together
pretty often
um to help us address those questions
and really give um our community the
fact-based answers to try to move us
along into getting us vaccinated so so
we don't have to deal with so many
variants and we don't have to deal with
the consequences of you know things
changing so often
i want to say something about that
because a lot of the big companies are
looking for a magic bullet
and i'll tell you there's no single
magic bullet it's a combination of
factors aside from vaccine you should
also continue wear masks and continue
your social distancing so all these
different factors should be a
combination of mitigation measures that
work but no single measure is affected
by itself even though we have effective
vaccine available
still
in southern nevada we only have a
vaccination full vaccination rate of
48.7
in other words the other half of our
population are not vaccinated so they
can continue to be
exposing other people if they're
infected and also worldwide you can see
that we may have higher rates of
vaccination with other countries the
poorer countries have no access to
vaccine so although effective blocks
available they don't have they can
actually because they're supported they
don't
have those uh vaccines available to them
so and
so i think as there's an equal
uh access of different vaccines it
will continue to be a big pandemic
because you need to reach at least 70
percent of population fully vaccinated
in order to reach the early unity and be
protected the
protective of the whole population
i just wanted to add um you know one
more point here um you know one of the
things that i'm hearing um especially in
you know populations that maybe don't
have access to things like child care
or if they're concerned that if they
have a side effect after getting the
vaccine that they can't take a day off
because of finances or because they
don't feel like they could take a day
off from their employer
i do think that the business community
can really
get out front of that and talk with
their employees if that is one of their
you know hesitations about getting the
vaccine
i know that the biden administration
specifically has put money aside and tax
credits for businesses
that want to allow their employees to
take a sick day that can be paid
as well as if they need to get child
care and so i think that's something
that we could do um just as a whole to
try to help people feel more comfortable
because finances are such a concern
right now um you know people our economy
is bustling right we've seen all these
tourists coming in town but there are
still people that
either have partial work and want to
work full-time or maybe the position
that they had before paid them more
money and so we do need to take those
financial things into consideration i
know that the state was considering
doing a hundred dollar voucher we had
the vax nevada days there's all these
things that people can get but i think
it's that that having that um
consistency and having um the
reliability
of those resources that really will help
people feel more comfortable making that
decision and then one more thing i just
wanted to say is i just wanted to
applaud caesars entertainment for having
this forum and for giving
myself and and our panelists here the
space and the platform to really talk
about things in a manner that is you
know easily uh digestible and you know
is from
people that are part of the bicoc
community
and really putting a friendly face on
things and and really
being committed to public health and
being on the forefront of what we need
to do as a city
because tourism and entertainment is
what we're built on and and we need to
all do this together
thank you for that dr madison appreciate
it
other thoughts on how we can get more in
the gaming hospitality industry
for example i've heard of other cities
who might um the city itself may have uh
funded you know a pretty sizable amount
of money going directly to service
providers to answer phone calls very
grassroots-oriented and and really
arming those service providers that the
bi-pop community knows and trusts um and
so it's very much of a
grassroots effort is that anything that
we're looking at in southern nevada
or or an effort that we might
engage or recommend to expand more of
the the grassroots efforts as well
you know we've taken on um you know
we're always open to different
approaches and one thing that we have
implemented recently or starting to
gradually get that on the ground is
canvassing efforts but absolutely we're
open to re-strategizing how we
communicate because we are at a kind of
a point in the pandemic where we need to
have more one-on-one conversations with
our community members about the
hesitancy that they're experiencing
about taking the vaccine and so we've
used our community partners um to canvas
efforts to canvas and do one and really
have that one-on-one conversation to
address those questions and any
opportunity in which
someone can talk to a trusted medical
provider i think is incredibly welcome
even for those that don't have a primary
i mean especially for those that don't
have a primary care provider and that
has been something that we've been
trying to fill that gap and that that is
really an essential point of like just
getting information that you feel is
trusted
so this is something that got brought up
on a recent phone call that i was part
of with immunized nevada so we we are
looking at um recruiting uh volunteer
providers to
help with fielding some of those phone
calls because we already have an
existing hotline for vaccines um so that
is something that is being discussed
right now um to be able to utilize that
a little bit more um robustly because
right now we're not the the people who
are answering those calls are
non-medical and so we are looking at
maybe having like you know office hours
but specifically for questions to
medical providers um
at the state level
thank you for that and i'm going to
encourage other questions to be
submitted there's about four of them
that i'm going to take momentarily i
mean i and as you all are sharing
it makes me think of conversations now
with community members or you know or
others today versus say months ago where
i feel like it's in a closeted state
right now
people may or may not admit whether or
not they're vaccinated or may not it's
this other layer of a barrier i think
that's happening so
some of us um earlier might have
mentioned
some questions coming in on
what would it take or what should i say
to a family member a friend i know dr c
said there's no magic bullet but if you
had
you know two things that
might be most influential for a family
member or friend who
may either be closeted not vaccinated or
very scared um what would you say
to them
and maybe it's not about the the science
right maybe it's about the heart tug
emotion i know this is a very different
kind of conversation but for some of it
it's like political campaigns right or
issues balance you you get around the
emotion no plug you don't get around the
the brain it's the heart right the heart
over the mind so any any thoughts about
that on some of the the questions that
were submitted earlier what would you
say to a
a friend or family uh to be most
influential if it wasn't around the
science it was another argument
anyway we're pulling a different side of
our brain i'm just kidding
honestly i think it's unfortunately it's
it's the sad stories right it's the
stories about the
you know the pregnant mom who is in the
hospital holding the hand of their
spouse that's now ventilated with kovid
not knowing whether or not they're going
to pull through to see their child
it's you know my husband who used to
work
in the gaming industry finding out on
the five o'clock news that one of his
co-workers that he used to work with
passed away from kovid and left five
children behind you know it's those
kinds of things um that unfortunately i
think is what's making the biggest
impact and then especially during
the surge that we're seeing right now
with delta i feel like fear has been the
biggest motivator and that people are
going because they fear
being hospitalized they fear
you know the what if like what if i get
sick with this and not even just what if
i get sick but what happens if i end up
with long-haul covid and the
complications following the infection
and so
as much as we want to spin it the
positive and be like oh you know we
should get vaccinated for your family
and your friends right it is sometimes
talking about the you know the sad
stories that we don't want people to end
up like because
you know honestly right now all of the
deaths that are happening are almost 100
completely preventable we have the tools
to prevent these people from dying
they're just not using them and
unfortunately it's because of the
misinformation it's because of social
media it's because of you know
people
thinking that somehow that we're trying
to brainwash them or microchip them or
whatever else you know reasons they
think about but honestly i just i just
want people to understand that it's not
just about you and your individual
self it's it's about the health and
wellness of our community and until we
can get
that into people's minds and actually
get them to have empathy for their
neighbor
and their friend or not even their
friend not somebody that they know but
somebody that could also be impacted
it's going to be so hard for us to get
past the you know the 48 fully
vaccinated that dr you know c mentioned
earlier um you know it's
we we've hit uh unfortunately we've hit
a block
and i don't know what else is going to
help other than fear and people not
wanting to get hospitalized
and i don't know if um i have any magic
words to that you know and i think that
when i think about
why i got vaccinated right this comes
down to
i feel a responsibility for my community
and i i feel like in public health we
are our brother's keepers right
and and that is what has driven
i'm sure everyone on this panel to work
70 hours a week probably more so every
week since the start of this pandemic
to try to sell to not sell that message
really to to express that commitment
not only to ourselves to our families
but to our community um and i and i
don't know how else to phrase that but
really about this sense of
responsibility for everyone in our
community regardless of your social
class regardless of your race ethnicity
that we have a responsibility to each
other and and i think to me that that's
the most i can share if i can't convince
you on the science
um
i want to convince you on the humanity
of it that we want to we have to pull
out of this and the only way to do that
is together
i appreciate that
extra three years actually
i think uh
yes we can i think we have done it
before with sars you can see that in
2003 were able to
prevent and control the spread of stars
and so i think
and
the other pandemic that we don't talk
about is the hiv pandemic i mean i was i
came to this country as a student and
that's when
i started to see in 1981 i can see at
that time day after day somebody would
be dying of aids now you don't hear that
anymore because we've developed very
effective anti-retroviral
therapy to treat them although
they still have hiv but it's just very
undetectable level which is not
transvisible anymore and they're able to
go back and work it's a manageable
disease although there's no vaccine for
it there's a treatment to suppress the
virus so the same thing is going to
happen with with the covered 19 if we
all uh
get vaccinated
wear a mass social distance we were able
to we would be able to
stop this pandemic so as
this panel uh
says earlier you know
we can stop it if we all work together
as a group each one teach one each one
rich one
i'm thinking about the most sealant
times i'm i'm older than my my hair
color looks uh and why i remember
driver's ed classes um the fear tactic
of
the gruesome scenes of the cars and the
teenagers who were in accidents i mean
literally it was very morbid that was
part of our education
and yes it was many years ago but the
the fear on the empathy and getting to
the heart and not the you know the brain
on wearing seat belts for example was
a training was one of my my most vivid
memories on a way to teach but but
educate and influence differently i have
to say that we should be extremely
morbid but uh that was
uh the empathy piece of it as well
um i'm going to go through my first i
had something on this before we go on
since since i come at this from a very
different angle i mean mine is just pure
science people are not asking me for
emotional arguments they want to know
facts and data but i think it's not what
i'm saying to them it's the fact that
i'm listening to them um and that to me
makes the biggest difference i'm not
dismissing the things that they say even
if it seems way out there to me for them
it's a valid concern and i address those
things factually but it's the fact that
they feel comfortable asking me the
question even if they might be
embarrassed about it do it public or
something like that but i'm going to
listen to that and give them an honest
answer i'm not trying to convince them
emotionally but i am being very honest
with them and i'm not
i'm not trying to make it seem better
than it is you know is the vaccine
perfect no it's not and i explained that
it largely works but it's not perfect
and why and all those sort of things so
so i think that winds up being the
important part is just listening to why
people have those concerns and uh before
we get into some of the trying to
convince them at least uh that's the way
i found it to be most effective in
getting people to change their mind
thank you for that
you know some of you mentioned alluded
to a few times earlier that the delta
variant is highly transmittable this is
a question from our audience
they request the
attendee is saying i'm not sure exactly
what what looks what it looks like in
real time for example if you're talking
with an infected to an infected person
face to face
and neither of you is wearing an n95
mask can you catch it if an infected
person is walking in front of you
sneezes or coughs and you follow closely
behind that person can you also catch
that as an example is the virus live
longer on surfaces and in the air what
exactly does this mean for the delta
variant
i can take this so
so the delta variant um the biggest
difference we see between the delta
variant the previous ones is that
if you get infected your viral load is
much higher so you're producing a lot
more virus in your body which means if
you're around other people there's more
virus for you to spread so as a result
it spreads more easily in a population
that is the simple difference it doesn't
cause a different disease doesn't live
longer in surfaces it's no different the
air the way we spread it is no different
just think of it as you sneezing ten
times instead of once there's just a lot
more stuff out there to spread to
somebody else um and as i say sneeze
christina did so uh
um with with this variant it's the same
mode of transmission as before if you're
face to face with somebody there is a
risk that you could transmit the virus
but it's not a guarantee if you're
walking behind somebody the more
distance between you and them the more
the virus is going to fall out of the
air that you're not going to be exposed
to but you happen to walk by a fan and
it blows it up and keeps it in the air a
little bit longer there's going to be
some increased risk there so so it's no
different than the previous uh virus
that the actions we take should be
exactly the same but now we also have
the vaccine that helps protect us when
all those things are not enough
thank you
other thoughts
anyone else i was just going to um just
add on the the aerosolized nature right
so like at the very beginning of the
pandemic we were not as sure about the
risk from surfaces and so even though
it's it's much lower i do want to
encourage people to continue to use hand
sanitizer and to wash their hands right
so it's multiple layers of public health
interventions that we're doing like mask
wearing vaccinating social distancing
and hand washing which is extremely
effective right um and so i did want to
just maybe briefly touch on ventilation
so that is something that
we know is impactful um and so you know
initially there was a study that was
done at a restaurant um where you saw
you know sort of multiple tables within
that restaurant from one person that was
in you know that was infected because
the ventilation system was actually
spreading the respiratory droplets
throughout the restaurant and so the
time the amount of time you spend
somewhere
without your mask on
is also part of this as well so when we
think about your level of risk tolerance
you need to think about what things
potentially and what places may be a
higher risk for you to end up with the
transmission of the virus so the more
people they are without an unknown
vaccine status that are not wearing
masks that are closely together and we
don't know what the ventilation system
is the increase of the risk for you to
potentially become infected and then
obviously we now know with delta
that you can still be vaccinated and
still get the virus and so
it's less likely but we are seeing some
of those breakthrough cases which is
also part of the new data that we saw
coming out of israel in the uk
for a more uh you know more of
a case to doing the booster doses coming
in september so
yeah just going on a booster dose
there's another question is the booster
different than the first vaccine or is
it the same shot just boosting the
original and the third booster should be
done
or is this
should this also be done roughly 30 days
after the second dose so i guess a few
questions and one about how different
this is the booster is from the first
vaccine
anyone want to take that
so it's the same
dose at this point we have not changed
it um all three of the vaccine
formulations that we have are still
quite robust against delta at this point
but the more we have unvaccinated um
individuals and a vector for the vex the
virus to change that could
you know that could be different story
right and so just wanted to to mention
that and as far as the timing and so
when we say booster that's really for
somebody who got an adequate immune
response from the first series of the
vaccine whether that was two of the
messenger rna are one of the of the
viral vector vaccine which is the jansen
vaccine and so at this point the
recommendation is eight months after you
received that second dose of the
messenger rna or
we're still waiting on information for
the jansen vaccine but it's looking like
more likely six months for that one
but again the data it hasn't been fully
published for that one we just got a
press release today
and so eight months after the second
dose of the messenger rna for your
booster and then potentially six months
after you got the
johnson and johnson vaccine and so
that's kind of where we're at right now
for the booster i do know there are
people that have either gone across
state lines or gone somewhere else or
told them oh i wasn't vaccinated
we are really encouraging people not to
do that um and if you are going to get
your booster that that booster dose
should be from that eight month window
and that you should get the same vaccine
that you started with so if you started
with pfizer you need to get a booster
with pfizer if you started with madura
you need to get a booster with moderna
and
having the fda approval should not be uh
something that you're concerned about
moderna likely will be come coming soon
because remember when we looked at when
these were authorized they were
authorized about a week apart from each
other so moderna is likely going to be
following suit as getting a full fda
approval hopefully soon
thank you
this message is for dr c um should that
should vaccines be providing full
immunity from covid why are some of
those who are vaccinated or still
getting it
those are what you call the breakthrough
infection and you know that our um
vaccines
for physical modern are they're both 95
effective
so you still have those five percent
that uh may not uh be protected and but
even though you're infected if you're
vaccinated you usually get very mild
infections so unlike those who are
unvaccinated if they're infected they
get very severe disease that would
result in hospitalization and probably
death so
that's how what's happening now so i
think
it's still very important to get
vaccinated because if you get infected
you still get a mild infection not the
severe one
i'm going to ask a
question generally speaking
you know what is your position on
employers mandating vaccines
and
you know how
i know your health professionals
but any any words of advice for people
asking in the audience
whether or not
you know
you would recommend employers do this or
not
maybe a healthy equity person like dr
marquez
if not
no sure
um you know i think we support efforts
that help us improve our vaccination
rates and from a health equity
standpoint we know our essential service
workers are predominantly
represented by ethnic minority
populations right and if we look at case
rate data hospitalizations death rates
you know amongst our native hispanic
african american we are over represented
in those in that data
um and we attend to be highly again
highly representative in those essential
service workers which increases our risk
of exposure so for us i think you know
it it is it's helpful for us and we
support those those efforts to increase
the vaccination rates amongst our
population
it really does help move that needle
forward where we're kind of at that
sticking point
are you saying that employers should
mandate that or not to put you on the
spot but that's
no it's a great question and you know i
think to be very fair and honest about
it i think they should raid we do have a
responsibility to protect those around
us this is not about a decision about
me and about all of us um and we have to
do our best to protect the safety of all
of those around us
okay so i'm gonna take the perspective
of a healthcare professional who's also
an academician
so all of my students that go out on
rotations and they're in a clinical
setting and are engaging in patient care
are all required to be up to date on
their vaccinations so i don't feel that
this is any different
especially when we're thinking about
this as what it is it's an infectious
communicable disease that is spread
easily in the air you don't even have to
try to get it you literally just have to
breathe so for me i think that this this
is not unusual this is not uncustomary
um i think that if you are in the public
and you are working with large groups of
people
that you should um protect yourself and
you should protect your patrons and i
think it's not just good public health
policy i think it's good business
because also you don't want your
employees to have to you know take time
off because they're sick or ill or if
you have some of your employees
vaccinated and some that aren't then you
end up having one employee test positive
and then anybody who worked with them
has to quarantine so again
this isn't just good public health
policy this is good business because you
can actually plan better for your future
of your business
and so um you know that's that's my
personal take on it obviously there
there could be some debate about that
but i think that this is this is
something that has been done and many
other things right child care
going to school
our children all before this all had to
have their routine recommended
vaccinations right and every time a new
vaccine came out and was recommended by
acip which is the authority
we added it to
to that list right and then now kids go
and they get their back to school shots
and then they're go back to school right
this is what has prevented us from
spreading illnesses for
decades it is one of the single most
successful public health stories
and interventions that we have in modern
medicine is the use of vaccinations
i agree with the two other finalists
that we should mandate um
mandatory uh vaccination
of our employees in the workplace not
only to protect ourselves but also to
protect our colleagues and also
customers especially
las vegas say
we depend so much on tourism if we can
assure our tourists that
our employees are all vaccinated then
they won't have any problem coming here
because they they feel safe you know and
but they have to also be sure that they
also get vaccinated so that they don't
mix with the other people and then
spread it so i think it uh i think i
agree with the other panels that we
should really uh require military
vaccination
hey thank you dr c any other thoughts dr
lavis
i don't think you're going to find a
public health person who says they don't
want to see everybody vaccinated um that
is our goal we want the population
protected because disease spreads among
the group not among individuals it if
the disease works its way into the
population we're all affected directly
indirectly we are a link in that chain
and so anything that we can do including
mandatory vaccinations of workplaces or
just like we did on college campuses
that drives us to a greater percentage
of people being vaccinated as well
thank you
speaking about
the viruses and changing and spreading
there's another question from the
audience given how quickly the virus can
mutate how concerned are you
about lambda
um i guess i'll start on this one i'm
not particularly concerned about lambda
um because essentially the virus has to
out-compete another virus and delta
spreads really easy right now lambda
does not seem to spread as easily as
delta it seems to spread more easily
than the previous variants but it's
basically a competition and right now
delta is winning that competition so
lambda isn't going to become the next
thing but every single person that is
infected has the potential to create the
next new variant so not only are you
stopping yourself from getting disease
if you can get vaccine you are stopping
the development of the variant that is
going to be worse than delta and will be
the next one that we really have to
worry about
thank you other thoughts
i agree with
brian about this and
if you look at uh cdc and the whole
classification of variants so there's
three groups so
the violence of concern are those that
are very transmissible including alpha
beta gamma and delta so those are the uk
south africa and brazil and indian
strain but then this other uh epsilon
ceta and gamma there belong to the
variants of interest let's just say uh
they're not as transmissible and also
they're more localized and so
and then the third group is really the
one that's resistant to vaccine and
treatment everything and so far we don't
have that kind of variant here so right
now we're just dealing with
the predominant strain we vary which is
the delta that's really
the most transmissive of all that we
have faced so far
i was just gonna say viruses want to
make more babies they want to make more
copies of themselves so stop giving them
a place to make more babies
get vaccinated
right this is what viruses want to do
and if we don't give it a host and a
vector for it to replicate then these
changes and mutations won't happen
thank you doctor
so just thinking about the last your
final thoughts for each of you how can
we all do our part uh to fight covet 19
and keep others safe i know you said it
shared a lot of ideas thoughts but just
as one one statement takeaway or a
couple from each of you could be a
resource could be a website it could be
others about how can they people get
involved what would be your last uh
thought on on how to to address the
crisis pandemic
let's start with dr marquez
sure um you know we have been directing
a lot of effort to nevada co-adviser to
find information
uh call the 800 number which is eight
1-800-401-0946 for information and
questions and if if there's anything i
can i can say
is really just make sure that the
sources and information you're getting
are the most reliable and if if you're
not sure please call one of this number
please check out the website
and we'll help you navigate those
questions
uh dr marquez would you mind putting
that in the chat to all absolutely
thank you
dr
for me it's uh a few words like and this
two shall pass if
we all do our role i'll play a role very
well like each one reach one you know
and
realize that we can do it so this to
show us
great thank you doctor
other words of advice doctor labas or
medicine
uh sure so i think
in america we love to think of ourselves
as individuals
and we have the freedom to do whatever
we want but when it comes to a disease
um it's not like that unfortunately
you can make whatever decisions you want
for yourself but they do affect
everybody around you and you have to
think of yourself as not an individual
but a link in a chain
you got the disease from somebody else
you're going to give it to somebody else
and two or three steps down the road you
could kill somebody's grandma because
you passed on that disease and so think
of the role you play in the community
and what you can do to protect yourself
by protecting everybody around you
thank you
and i just want to tell people that this
is not a
it's not a fight this is this is not a
war between the vaccinated and the
unvaccinated
we honestly just want everybody to be
protected and so please make sure that
you're getting your questions answered
if you are
on the fence about getting vaccinated
talk to your doctor talk to your
pharmacist talk to somebody that you
like know and trust
and ultimately
if you do become positive with covid19
don't forget that you can get treatment
with monoclonal antibodies this is
another free resource just like the
vaccine that you can get that works best
if you get it within 7 to 10 days of
testing positive also if you've been
exposed to somebody who's tested
positive but you are still negative you
can get monoclonal antibodies to prevent
yourself from getting covid19 so you can
go to combat covid and i'll put it in
the chat
and you can put in your zip code and you
can find out where there's an infusion
center close to you and you can get that
resource and again it is free just like
the vaccination and um my last three
things that i'll say is masked up backs
up and wash up
that's great insight thank you so much
doctor and the rest of you on the panel
you know i i think there's there's also
one more website that i was looking at
uh in preparation of this it's a pretty
impressive website it's the nevada
minority health and equity coalition
website some of the doctors on this
panel have authored some of the
resources there's a few brochures that
you can download as well
very quick reference guides and there's
a contact us tab as well so i encourage
you all to look at that too i want to
thank the panelists today very
insightful crisp clear question
questions and answers i really
appreciate this this uh this background
that you're sharing with us today
know that we're broadcasting this as
well and recording it for further use
and uh thank you very much for all the
attendees
have a great rest of your day
take care thank you